there were thousands of people that
showed up because I guess they wanted a
PlayStation and then once once they're
all there dude social order breaks down
that's it you know what I was thinking
watching this video
it's like The Purge but in slow motion
everywhere because there was that woman
in Portland she got punched in the face
and now she's a republican you've got
Walgreens getting shut down you've got
Target stores locking every product
they're the Walgreens in Chicago where
they don't have products anymore have
you seen this well I've seen where
everything's locked up no no in
Walgreens you walk into the Chicago
Walgreens there's no products at all you
walk up to a terminal and you type in
what you want and someone will carry it
out for you if you pay for it like from
like a back armor browsing they're
taking all the fun out of shopping but
you know what's funny is Amazon tried
doing that thing in Seattle where you
could walk in and take whatever you
wanted could you imagine what it would
be like if they put it in San Francisco
I mean maybe they have one I don't know
but you know Port where was it was in
Seattle yeah I was in Seattle they put
it in San Francisco Seattle's bad enough
but it's not as bad